hey friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  answering the question how to focus  when learning a language if there is one  luxury  and one power we have to make things  better  is be able to focus for an extended  period of time  so here's my piece of advice in this  regard if you want to make it happen  every single day  and laser focus on your language make  sure that you declutter your space  and then you remove all possible  distractions be it social media  destruction from colleagues or from your  family so that you create  an inspirational effective productive  environment for your daily  language session this is going to make a  huge  difference the devil as i say is in the  details if you want to know more about  language learning  please check out my channel over and out